SANDEEP DINESH: The first step
in deploying to Kubernetes
is putting your app
inside a container.
But why stop there?
In this episode of
"Kubernetes Best Practices,"
let's explore how you can create
small and secure container
images.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Thanks to Docker,
creating container images
has never been simpler.
Specify your base image.
Add your changes, and
build your container.
While this is great for getting
started, using the default
base images can lead to
large images full of security
vulnerabilities.
Most Docker images use Debian
or Ubuntu as the base image.
While this is great
for compatibility
and easy onboarding,
these base images
can add hundreds of megabytes
of additional overhead
to your container.
For example, simple
Node.js and Go,
"hello world" apps are
around 700 megabytes.
Your application is probably
only a few megabytes in size.
So all this
additional overhead is
wasted space and a
great hiding place
for security
vulnerabilities and bugs.
So let's look at two methods
to reduce the container image
size--
using small base images and
using the builder patcher.
Using smaller base images
is probably the easiest way
to reduce your container size.
Chances are your language
or stack that you are using
provides an official
image that's
much smaller than
the default image.
For example, let's take a
look at our Node.js container.
Going from the default node:8 to
node:8-alpine reduces our base
image size by 10 times.
To move to a smaller base
image, update your Docker
file to start with
a new base image.
Now, unlike the
old onbuild image,
you need to copy your
code into the container
and install any dependencies.
In the new Docker file,
the container starts with
the node:alpine image, creates
a directory for the code,
install dependencies
with NPM, and finally,
starts the Node.js server.
With this update, the
resulting container
is almost 10 times smaller.
If your programming
language or stack
doesn't have an option
for a small base image,
you can build your
container using raw Alpine
Linux as a starting point.
This also gives you
complete control
over what goes inside
your containers.
Now, using a small base
image is a great way
to quickly build
small containers.
But you might be able to go
even smaller using the builder
pattern.
With interpretive
languages, the source code
is sent to an interpreter, and
then it is executed directly.
But with a compiled
language, the source code
is turned into compiled
code beforehand.
Now, with compile languages,
the compilation step
often requires tools
that are not needed
to actually run the code.
So this means that you
can remove these tools
from the final
container completely.
To do this, you can use
the builder pattern.
The code is built in
the first container,
and then the compiled code is
packaged in the final container
without all the compilers
and tools required
to make the compiled code.
So let's take a Go application
through this process.
First, let's move from the
onbuild image to Alpine Linux.
In the new Docker file,
the container starts with
a golang:alpine image.
Then it creates a directory for
the code, copies in the source
code, builds the source, and
then finally starts the app.
This container is much smaller
than the onbuild container,
but it still contains a
compiler and other Go tools
that we really don't need.
Let's extract just the
compiled program out and put it
into its own container.
So you might notice something
strange about this Docker file.
It has two FROM lines.
The first section looks exactly
the same as the previous Docker
file, except that it
uses the AS keyword
to give this step a name.
In the next section,
there is a new FROM line.
This will start a fresh
image, and instead of using
golang:alpine, we will use
raw alpine as the base image.
Raw Alpine Linux doesn't have
any SSL certificates installed,
which will make most API
calls over HTTPS fail.
So let's install some
root CA certificates.
And now comes the
interesting part.
You can use the COPY command
to copy the compiled code
from the first container
into the second.
This line will copy just
that one file and not
the rest of the Go tooling.
This new multistage Docker
file contains a container image
that's just 12 megabytes.
The original container
image was 700 megabytes.
That is quite a difference.
Using small base images
and the builder pattern
are great ways to create
much smaller containers
without a lot of work.
Now, depending on your
application stack,
there may be additional ways
to reduce your container image
size as well.
But do small containers actually
have a measurable advantage?
Let's look at two areas where
small containers shine--
performance and security.
For performance,
let's look at how long
it takes to build a container,
push it to a registry,
and then pull it down
from the registry.
For the initial
build, you can see
that the smaller container has
a huge advantage over larger
containers.
Docker will cache layers so
subsequent builds will take
very little time for either.
But for many CI systems that
folks use to build and test
containers, they
don't cache layers,
so there is a significant
time saving here.
Just think about how many times
you're building and testing
your code.
Now that the container
is built, you
need to push it to
a container registry
so you can use it in
your Kubernetes cluster.
I recommend using the
Google Container Registry.
You only pay for the
raw storage and network.
There is no additional
fee to manage containers.
It's private and secure,
and it's lightning fast.
In fact, GCR uses many
tricks to speed up pushing.
You can see that
the time to push
both the containers
for the large machine
is almost the same.
This is because GCR uses a
global cache for common base
images, meaning you don't
need to upload them at all.
With the small machine, the
CPU becomes the bottleneck.
As you can see, there is
still a significant advantage
to use small containers.
If you're using Google
Container Registry,
I highly recommend using
Google Container Builder
as part of your build system.
As you can see, it's much
faster to build and push
than even the large machine.
And you get a 120 build
minutes free per day,
which should be enough
to cover most people's
container-building needs.
Now comes the most important
performance metric--
pulling the container.
While you might not care
about the time it takes
to build and push
a container, you
should really care
about the time
it takes to pull the container.
For example, let's say you have
a three node cluster and one
of the nodes crashes.
If you're using a managed system
like Google Kubernetes Engine,
the system will
automatically spin up
a new node to take its place.
However, this new node
will be completely fresh
and will have to pull
all your containers
before it can start working.
If it takes too long
to pull the containers,
this is just time where your
cluster isn't performing
as well as it should.
Now, there are many cases
where this may occur,
such as adding a new
node to your cluster,
upgrading your nodes,
or even switching
to a new container
for your deployments.
So minimizing pull
times becomes key.
You can easily tell
the smaller container
is much faster than
the large container.
And you're probably
running multiple containers
on your Kubernetes cluster, so
these times can add up quickly.
Using small, common base
images for your containers
significantly speeds
up the deployment
times and speed at
which new Kubernetes
nodes can come online.
Now let's look at security.
People often say
that containers are
more secure if they're smaller,
because they have less surface
area for attacks.
Let's see if this
is actually true.
An awesome feature of
Google Container Registry
is that it can automatically
scan your containers
for vulnerabilities.
So I built both the onbuild
and multistage containers
a few months ago.
Let's see if there's
any vulnerabilities
in these old images.
Wow, there's only 3
medium vulnerabilities
for the small container,
but 16 critical and over 370
for the larger container.
If we drill into the
larger container,
we can see that
most of the issues
have nothing to
do with their app,
but rather programs that
we're not even using.
When people talk about
an increased surface
area for attacks, this is
what they're referring to.
So remember-- build
small containers.
The performance and
security benefits are real.
I'll see you on the next episode
of "Kubernetes Best Practices."
[MUSIC PLAYING]